>>Whitney: The School of the Future
is a six through twelve public school
in District Two in New York City.
It's located on the
corner of 22nd Street
and Lexington Avenue in Manhattan.
>>John: I have to usually answer why
it's called "School of the Future."
Half the people think we beam people
up to the Star Trek Enterprise.
But actually what I say is
that School of the Future,
although originally was named for
Macintosh computers, my partner
and I feel that School of
the Future now is a spearhead
of progressive education that
is rigorous and accountable.
>>Stacy: And we're continuing
to be a progressive school,
but also to figure out how
we are folding in assessment
and folding in accountability.
I think what makes authentic
assessment authentic is
that it's actually the
kind of work that a person
in that discipline would do.
A science authentic assessment
would challenge the kids
to do the same kind of task that
a scientist would actually do.
>>Esther: We're trying to give work
that either mirrors what they
might be doing later in life,
or will prepare them
for those kind of tasks,
or is simply meaningful to them.
>>Andy: In terms of authentic
work within the school,
it needs to be something that
the student really cares about,
and that the teacher
really cares about.
So if we want a school where it's
just really making real change
and really addressing
students in their hearts,
then we can't have curriculum that
is just going through the motions.
>>Whitney: And then
the other piece is
that making sure the task
is a synthesis type of task.
That will ensure the
critical thinking necessary
to feel that rigor is happening.
>>Mike: I think of authentic
assessment as a window
into the true understanding
of the student.
>>Whitney: It makes
teaching much more efficient.
You think that it takes
all this time,
but in fact it's far more
targeted and efficient,
and it really speeds things up.
>>Mike: I think first about what
are the big ideas I want them
to come away with.
Some may argue that's curriculum,
but I think it's even more
fundamental than curriculum.
What are the big things
I want the students
to be able to walk away with?
>>Whitney: The key is asking
yourself, "How will I know?"
And ask that upfront as you're
doing backwards planning.
What does that learning look like?
What does it sound like?
What would I be hearing?
What would I be seeing on paper?
And then based on that, creating
whatever assessment tool works best
for you.
>>Mike: When you're starting
to plan your curriculum,
start with-- all right.
What are the three assessments then?
The three big ones that
I'm going to see whether
or not they got these skills,
and then you can start think
of smaller assessments on their way.
They're little check-ins.
And then designing the activities
that go along with does this activity
that I normally do, does it
address what I really want them
to understand?
>>Andy: I've been teaching
now for about 13 years,
and a lot of educational
fads have come and gone.
But one that I believe
is hopefully here with us
to stay is precisely this question
of how do we know they got it?
Before, sometimes it felt like
if we taught a great lesson
and the students were nodding
a lot, and maybe writing
in their notebooks, we felt good.
But now we have to find out did they
actually understand the material we
were teaching them?
Are they connecting this to
their own intellectual interests?
Is it authentic for them?
Was there real learning
that happened there?
And I think we're getting better
at doing that as teachers.
I think we're getting
better at doing that.